hey guys ryan right here and alyssa
alyssa be crazy
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
jupiter ascending the second trailer and
do you know anything about this no i
just it sounds like space it deals with
space in some fashion and it has
channing tatum in it mila koontz in it
i love her fun fact about me is channing
tatum's neck really freaks me out i
don't know why
i think he has like elf ears in this one
or something like that alyssa people can
barely see her face
there we go oh
yes alyssa and i are filming something
to say something listen i filmed
something today
it's an april fool's day uh short film
alyssa fools alyssa fool's day it stars
yours truly and alyssa at one point i
had to be naked when we filmed one point
she was butt naked
and i didn't know she was naked
and like the smart woman she is when i
had to look at her for the shot
she looked directly into my eyeballs
so i went okay be a gentleman
look at her eyeballs
little did i know if she had been naked
i would have said [ __ ] the whole
gentleman thing let's look at those
boobies and ass
butts
did not get that opportunity
so you notice yeah i had i didn't even
know
until i was like wait why is there bra
lying here and then i was like oh my god
she was naked the whole time and i could
have totally looked
anyway
straight eye contact yeah just if i
didn't make that eye contact with her i
would have i wouldn't have
bothered to look this is true story guys
it's a real bummer for me you're gonna
get to see the exact situation on april
so keep an eye out keep an eye out for
the short film you're gonna know the
exact moment that happened
yeah so
i guess i'm excited to watch this
trailer okay wachowski brothers directed
this movie or richowski's siblings
because one of them's like a woman now
or something do you know they are no
they did the matrix yes i know that from
family guys and so uh yep let's watch
this [ __ ] trailer finally let's do it
there was a hunter
make sure this is the right one bane
it's her okay kill
her oh hell yeah
there goes shannon
who are you
king wise i'm here to help you
what
he's here to help her that's so weird to
know what in is going on i love her
i think when you fight has stumbled into
a war with some of the most powerful
dynasties in the universe why is this
happening to me
you're a royalty
your majesty you are in for a surprise
when you find out what i do for a living
this feels like a fairy tale you do yeah
oh cool music majesty's life has got to
change why
help me
dude that makeup does not look
believable to the very
kind of looks like star wars
yeah star wars star trek yeah a little
bit thorough do you claim it yeah
i will harvest that planet tomorrow
before i let her take it i will wait a
minute she was in les
we need firepower using 21 jump street
firepower is always the best tool that's
cool
whoa what the [ __ ] is
this looks like a sci-fi fantasy i know
it looks amazing
here we go
me too man my nipples are so hard right
now that was really really that was
really cool so i guess she's someone
important they have to protect her
simple premise but simple premise with
great detail equals awesome [ __ ]
movie yeah it's cool to see the
wachowski brothers back in this type of
uh science fiction universe dealing with
hardcore action right now yeah so did
you see the matrix
you're going to hate me so much right
now
i
saw the matrix but i hated it could not
could not get through it couldn't do it
hate it won't see a second one i will i
will give it a second chance just for
benefit of the doubt but i just years
ago i did not like it it sparked a
huge thing with my friends
it did
you've just created a new enemy this
does look cool though this looks really
cool it looks like it's going to be
easier to follow than the matrix
probably it does look like it's inspired
by a lot of stuff like the matrix look
like this has never been done before
this kind of looks like it yeah it's
been done before but a little more
inspirational it's going to be good
though it's going to be good we gotta
end this video right now and i'm gonna
try to make out with her again hopefully
it goes according to plan she's going
home that's what happens every [ __ ]
girl on this damn channel oh but oh but
before we go
subscribe
i actually forgot first look at what i
was supposed to say if you're still
watching this and you haven't subscribed
to him
subscribe to her also last time i said
oh it's really cool we have to see this
movie divergent like a day or two later
he freaking goes and sees divergent
without me
dude i have to review it no
you could have you didn't even i went to
like a real i went to a 9am show i would
have gone if he at 9am yes now that that
is said and you guys are mad at him for
doing that without me now that i'm
saying about this one we have to go
we'll go together
number three do you get scared easily
can i put my arm around you can i do the
whole like eighth grade flopping my hand
down on the cup holder hoping you'll
grab my hand thingy no can't do any of
that
what a [ __ ]
oh i wanted to give a shout out to a
couple people too bicknell 67 you're the
[ __ ] dude your shits are awesome you you
should [ __ ] more often because they are
incredible epic five productions i
believe you requested a shout out
so shout out
there's so many of you guys that i
remember that i try to space it out
throughout the videos he has a good
memory though and uh evonder or evander
whatever the evan j show you know
i believe you're a black dude i need to
know more black friends i need to know
more of my black friends is that what it
said i want to know more black guys
black guys are cool that's what i've
learned lately and you just look cooler
having a black friend don't you come on
it's like that guy is cool with black
people you are automatically cool
because you know it's like black people
are they're the [ __ ] so you know you
automatically look cooler when you're
friends with black people everyone is
not black knows what i'm talking about
so thank you for subscribing